let's go right now to cbs news senior
national security analyst fran townsend
she joins us she was homeland security
advisor to president george w
bush fran good morning to you let's
start where jeff's
piece ended with the question of ransoms
jbs we don't know if they paid but
colonial pipeline paid nearly five
million dollars and in 2020 alone
some 350 million dollars was paid by
other companies
to clear these ransomware attacks so
simple question
complicated answer is it a good idea for
companies to pay up
you know tony we have some experience
with this in hostage taking we have a
national policy that we do not
pay ransoms uh for the release of
hostages
we ought to have a similar national
policy here
the the ex but there need to be
exceptions right there needs to be
discretion
one these attacks have to be notified
very quickly to the federal government
the federal government will have a view
as to whether this is an isolated
incident or whether this is part of a
broader attack
and then depending on the the victim of
the attack
uh there ought to be discretion about
whether or not where lives lives are at
stake not
revenue um the ability to pay the ransom
yeah if you pay it's going to keep
happening i have a question about the
technology behind
this is our cyber security itself
what's vulnerable making our systems
vulnerable or are people just making
simple mistakes with emails opening up
the wrong link and in essence letting
the bad guys in
tony i think it's a little bit of both
right think about here in the united
states
um we've gone from about 11 billion
devices and
7 billion devices in 2011 to now having
25 billion devices
that attack surface that vulnerability
is just bigger
by virtue of our connectedness that's
part of the problem
people do it's a part it's education
inside companies about
clicking on emails checking who the
sender is before you open an attachment
so there's an education element to this
and then lastly i would say
many of these companies have been much
more focused on physical
security the pipeline the gates and
right the gates and guards around the
outside
meat packing plants are understandably
focused on food security
and so i don't think enough attention or
money has been
spent on cyber security that's also for
big public companies tony that's a
problem because their boards and
the management will be held responsible
fran
one quick question here about what the
white house should do
with regard to these attacks the
attackers are believed to be based in
russia other attackers have been in
china
how aggressive should washington be in
response
well as we know president biden has a
meeting coming up with vladimir putin
he's going to have to raise this
i think president biden rightly in his
most recent executive order is
calling for a global coalition to hold
those nation states who
harbor these criminals accountable
that'll mean things like sanctions
i agree with secretary panetta these
really become military weapons
but not every deployment by a
nation-state is an act of war and so we
need a national policy so we understand
and consistently approach these problems
with our foreign adversaries yeah we
call it a wake-up call we need to wake
up fran townsend thank you very much we
appreciate it